hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen hier meine lieben zuschauer
zu einem spiel das eigentlich gar nicht
sein kann dass hier ist kevin und kevin
meine damen und herren ist die
hauptfiguren beziehungsweise die einzige
figur in diesem spiel was steht in kevin
also breitbeinig rum wir können auf
jeden fall einen seiner arme nehmen
einfach mal hoch ziehen und fallenlassen
dann seht ihr schon mehr kevin fällt
runter stellt sich aber automatisch
kevin wird sich vielleicht mal wieder
hinstellen
er stellt sich dann auf jeden fall
automatisch wieder hin wir können noch
an einem bein nehmen und können ihn
runter fallen lassen aber wir können
nicht nur fallen lassen sondern auch
einfach mal gegen eine wand und
beispielsweise noch mal und dann können
wir fangen der luft und aufbauen
[Musik]
das hier ist nun kevin meine damen und
herren das ist ein unterkörper den was
ist denn wenn ich das hier ist auf jeden
fall so noch seinen unterkörper das
können wir
[Musik]
mit komplett weg allerdings sagen wir so
einen schönen knopf und zwar das kreuz
und dann ins kevin wieder da wir haben
allerdings nicht nur kevin in diesem
spiel sondern wir haben ja der seite
auch schon verschiedene symbole wie
beispielsweise in warmen da können wir
jetzt im hintergrund ändern da finde ich
weiß allerdings eigentlich schon ganz
cool
wir können allerdings auch auf sport
klicken und dann sehen wir schon können
wir eine zweite person ihr
beispielsweise hinstellen und auch noch
eine dritte aber noch tausend andere
sachen bevor wir allerdings kompletten
schwachsinn mit diesem ganzen dinge
anstellen werden seht ihr hier oben
schon werbe video eingeblendet und zwar
ist dieses video finanziell unterstützt
worden von ryan adams das hieß früher
rise of civilizations wurde jetzt
allerdings umbenannt zu rise of kingdoms
so sieht das ganze aus als auf kingdom
stets darum dass es elf königreiche gibt
aus denen man wählen kann und die
schlachten findet in echtzeit statt also
so wie man es allgemein von
strategiespielen am pc kennt es gibt
einen realistischen tag und nachtwechsel
der viele möglichkeiten bietet seinen
gegner beispielsweise nach zu
überraschen hand zu greifen und es gibt
einen neuen crossgate warfare modus der
das game halt zusätzlich noch spannender
macht und seit neuestem gibt es auch
noch drei neue königreiche doch die
byzantiner die osmanen und die araber
alle königreich an beide wayne eigenen
team song von zweifachen grammy award
gewinner christopher tin komponiert
wurde und außerdem gibt es bei reis auf
kingdoms jetzt einen neuen spielmodus
namens oco cyrus battleground da können
verschiedene allianzen gebildet werden
und auf dem schlachtfeld gegen andere
antreten
wir finden den link dazu und in der
video beschreibung und jetzt gehen wir
zurück zu kevin wir haben hier im
sportbereich nämlich nicht nur den kevin
sondern wir haben auch andere
gegenstände wie beispielsweise einen
der mittlerweile schon drei leute im das
ist ja der kevin die anarbeiten können
wir mal kann mir die nicht komplett
zerstören so jetzt ist nur noch der
kevin und der kopf von diesem anderen
übrig er allerdings nicht und quadrat
sondern auch einen eher dreieck ein
knopf den können wir hier hinsetzen und
der knopf den können wir verbinden mit
anderen gegenständen wie beispielsweise
drohen sfeir detektors proximity ist ein
ass et cetera ppm ich will allerdings
noch weiter wir hier vorne gehen zu den
waffen und zwar mit zb schon hier ein
energies ort und das können wir auch
nicht so klein lassen sondern kann
einfach die pfeiltaste gedrückt halten
dann haben wir so hin gleich das mal mit
gewinnen ein paar sekunden später allein
dadurch dass ich kämpfen da drauf gelegt
habe wurde er schon komplett
zerschnitten ist aber gar nicht weiter
schlimm freunde wie klickt er war wieder
auf das kreuz oben alles ist wieder beim
staat wie am kevin staaten jetzt nehmen
wir einfach das normale energies ort in
der größe und können
kevin
ja damit komplett das ist kevin man kann
auf jeden fall einigen schwarze mit
diesen schwertern machen wichtig
allerdings mal wieder auf das kreuz
drauf und zeigt euch mal dass noch
andere dinge gibt die beispielsweise
einen fan
das ist das was ich nicht habe den
machen wir es mal ein bisschen größer
stellen ihnen hier neben kevin und jetzt
können wir hier einfach den fern
gedrückt halten und f drücken
und ja
ich stelle den fan jetzt mal hierhin ich
habe den grat noch ein bisschen größer
gemacht und dann nehme ich mal dass
energies ort und stelle das hierhin das
heißt wir haben jetzt theoretisch wenn
ich f drücke kettenreaktion ich bin
quasi wie albert einstein
ich mache auch experimente allerdings
haben ja nicht nur das energies fort und
stellen sondern wir haben auch noch
force viel und da seht ihr schon
m
also wer
ein kraftfeld sobald ich rausgehe ist er
halt wieder normal aber sobald ich den
rein packe sieht so aus wie so eine
tanzende prinzessin der war noch eine
graffiti grady kann ich einfach mal
fallen lassen
da passiert gar nichts oder muss ich
hier a
okay ich habe sie jetzt aktiviert
gewünscht aber das spannendste sind
wirklich die waffen die es hier gibt ich
verstehe geraten nur nicht wo die sind
wir haben hier eine was das ist eine
rakete der kevin tut mir tatsächlich ein
bisschen leid dem jetzt wieder oben auf
das kreuz gedrückt das heißt der
campbell ist wieder ganz aber ich muss
wirklich noch einmal so machen und alter
das ist schon eher der kevin den wir
kennen die haben also raketen slow
vieles ist das ist nicht richtig sehe
okay der kevin hat geht das immer
schneller oder was jetzt ist er
wenigstens elektrisiert mal schauen was
wir noch so haben tesla keul
ich weiß nicht genau was das ist ich
packe ihn einfach mal hierhin und jetzt
nehmen wir mal kevin und ziehen ihn mal
hier drauf passiert
aber hauptsache sein körper da springt
auch trampolin
nun sind wir hier bei den waffen
angekommen das hier ist die treysaer
dann machen wir auch mal ein bisschen
größer als können wir elf drücken und
dann einfach schießen
ich verstehe nur nicht was beim kevin
jetzt passiert ja
er will muss da rein fliegen und jetzt
dann als nicht zum erfolg er wird übrig
von daher klicken wir auch wieder auf
das kreuz im schauen uns mal weiterhin
was sie noch ist anders tätig was ist
das denn
sorry kevin wir haben hier noch einen
neuen arm
ja super wir haben doch nur neue bände
gladbeck defibrillator drohen hier als
man kann ganz ganz ganz ganz viele
sachen machen jetzt einfach einen fuß
von kevin hier
ich stelle mir einen überdimensionalen
fuß neben dem ich kann er sich da drauf
setzen
dumpfe alles ja wir noch hier great
lakes medical scanner mit kick thermomed
thermometer
a 37 grad hat das bein allerdings will
ich jetzt mal endlich zu den richtigen
waffen hier kommen habe ich bleibe hat
die ganze zeit hängen bei solchen sachen
was ist denn barrel einfach ein kanister
oder was hat jetzt eine biene
ist da werden da werden bienen
freigesetzt sechs ende heraus lake steel
gespannt das heißt ich jetzt mal einfach
auf die alle hier drauf ich merke schon
wie dieser dieses browsergame ich gerade
übels am lenges alter
das ist so wie im sommer bei mir in der
wohnung oh mein gott eine cluster
granate war dein knie ist noch eine
flash granate ich glaube die macht
die man dem handy macht einfach kurz
alles hell jetzt oder wie die haben ja
auf jeden fall unfassbar viele sachen
ich will einfach nur was ist das eine
mini nukes das ist das erste mal dass
kevin komplett zerstört wurde es gibt
auf jeden fall so unfassbar viele sachen
es gibt auch ein schwarzes loch
wenn ja cool jetzt ist
schon wieder weg ich mache jetzt mal ein
unfassbar riesiges schwarzes loch und
pax hier oben in die ecke
ja das kann man auch direkt weg wir
haben ja auf jeden fall unfassbar 1000
millionenfache items irgendwie gefühlt
also es nimmt wirklich gar kein ende
hier ich kann auch einfach auf random
klicken und dann seht ihr schon was da
alles da ist also was ist das ein boom
stuff also letztendlich ist es ziel des
spiels kevin komplett zerstört wird ich
fand das spiel auf jeden fall mal ganz
cool so für zwischendurch im kevin und
ich würde uns an der stelle jetzt auch
von euch verabschieden jazzfreunde
schaut euch hat das video hier gefallen
wenn sie das getan hat dann will ich
mich sehr über einen daumen hoch von
euch freuen schreibt wir gerne unten in
die kommentare ich das ganz normal
spielen soll
denn es gibt wirklich unfassbar viele
möglichkeiten die wir noch gar nicht
alle ausgenutzt haben und deutlich sie
ihr da beenden
[Musik]